the the opposite of what people think
people think you should go learn some
secrets theories that you don't know
and then you need to like develop your
own voice and like come up with original
content it's like actually that's a
really slow way to get better
[Music]
so i was saying i i have a lot to ask
you about this document what did you say
i said are you going to ask me about my
fresh green smoothie
maybe my green goddess salad or maybe
the green can of mountain dew
giant steak that the chef made you know
what kind of life am i living here this
is an incredible life um well i would
say
maybe like now is not the best time to
eat a salad and a steak
maybe like later it's like you literally
are eating a steak right now yeah i took
one bite right the countdown to
recording was like five four three two
one i was like i gotta get it in um
before we really get into stuff um
so did you see that picture that i
shared of you when we first started
recording
yeah
that was great so and i was kind of
reflecting on it and the reason i was
reflecting on it is the hustle like the
the the newsletter the hustle has a
daily podcast coming out and they've
worked on it for like months when we
started
i mean you rented a studio at first but
then it was you and i like i'm pretty
sure we just used our iphone headphones
and we were in that shitty like closet
yeah we were in a club we were basically
in a closet with on a table where we
were so close together that any time i
talked your mic picked it up anytime you
dug my bank so it's like an awful awful
recording you can see the in the photo
you posted about like us recording
i'm like hunched over i got my glasses
on i didn't wear my contacts i'm wearing
my jacket still because i just walked
over from my office and just like we
started recording instantaneously i'm
looking at my phone
you know like
uh
really wasn't you know
you know some people are like you know
you wear a suit you know act like act
like you you're gonna be where you want
to be or whatever uh i definitely wasn't
doing that i was just sort of like uh
whatever none of this video stuff
matters all that matters is the audio
let's just do that
which wasn't entirely wrong but what
what i was proud of was that when we did
it like we really often times we would
just use the iphone and just like an
audio file and
the uh
like i said i'm recording this on an
iphone are you you're using your iphone
or using the fancy well we have fancy
mics now but like there was one time
where i remember like we literally like
it was like a speaker phone and an
iphone but the the hustle guys they've
got this podcast coming out and they're
doing it every day i'm and i'm going to
pop on it sometimes i
they're going to ask you to pop on it
sometimes too but they're doing a daily
podcast i think it's going to work it's
so it's so much work though daily like
about the news about what yeah they're
doing it's called the hustle daily show
so it's easy right and they're doing a
podcast every single day it launches
wednesday and um
we were talking about i just left a
meeting where i was helping them get it
off the ground and i was like
what i told them was
it's gonna work right away i think so
like when your
episodes when it was just you came out
it took off right away but then it goes
down when like the when the novelty
wears off
and that's when you've got to like
actually develop this skill and i would
actually say
sean i would say you started out pretty
great but then and i would say i started
out decently as well decent as well but
then we like developed the skill and
that's like when it really starts
getting good and i'm like don't forget
guys when you start doing this it's like
a skill this isn't like
some people like you were talented but
you still have to like hone this in
yeah and by the way the best way to do
that is just to be a fan of other
people's work uh because if you're a fan
of other people's work you'll pick up on
the little things that they do
that um
it's like man why do i love this i love
this because blah blah blah and you're
never gonna recreate that but if you see
five examples then you start to realize
what the bar is and where you need to be
and so it's like you you talk about this
with copywriting how do you become a
better copywriter
it's actually other people's work the
opposite of what people think people
think you should go learn some secrets
theories that you don't know
and then you need to like develop your
own voice and like come up with original
content it's like actually that's a
really slow way to get better the way
you get better is you do copy work which
is you write other people's you
literally hand write
word for word what somebody who's
writing you love what they do and uh you
write that and i do this still i do it
as a warm-up basically so if i'm gonna
write something i'll first spend five
ten minutes and actually i wanna one of
the pieces i copy work is yours you have
something that you have this post it's
very hard to find because every time i
want it it's so hard for me to go find
it again so you need to like put this
front and center somewhere which points
but basically it starts with
let's let me be perfectly clear
you're reading this because i want you
to yes that's a good one right
yeah it's like i'm casting a spell but
i'm not forcing you to do something you
don't want to do you want to know what
i'm talking about and you like write it
like that and so and i know it because
i've copywritten this same thing like a
bunch of times
and um and i just love that let me be
perfectly clear let's be perfectly clear
it's so good and then you're like you're
reading this because i want you to every
line is getting you to further down the
slippery slope and you're like you're
explaining what's going on uh so that
one that one is brilliant i love that
one that you do i have another one
that's uh the scott adams one
the day you became a better writer yeah
he goes um
in the first sentence is like the most
important part of that whole thing
right
i forget the i forget it what was it do
you remember i don't know ben pull that
up but but basically
this method is actually applicable to
many things so if you want to learn uh
you know how to play the guitar you can
first learn all the scales and you can
learn music theory and then you can try
to write original songs but man that
would be a really hard way to do it the
better way is you take a song you like
you figure out how to play those four
chords and you're like okay so you play
covers right yeah and you play a shitty
cover initially then you get better and
better then you might add your own twist
to it and you go from there
ben make that bigger i can't i can't uh
i can't see it you know this is what is
this screen for ants
so this is written by the guy who
created dilbert who's a beautiful writer
i i can't read it from here what's that
first
i went from being a bad writer to a good
writer after taking a one day course in
quote-unquote business writing i
couldn't believe how simple it was i'll
tell you the matrix here so you don't
have to waste a day in class it's great
and then he references the first article
and he goes by the way the first what's
he say the first sentence is like the
most important thing go re-read that
sentence up that i wrote when we started
this out i read i wrote and rewrote that
dozens of times
it makes you curious that's the key and
then he goes write short sentences avoid
putting multiple thoughts in one
sentence readers aren't as smart as
you'd think
it goes on and on um but it's a short
very short post but it's very good
and um and so yeah whether you want to
if you want to learn to cook
first start with recipes nail those then
do original creations if you want to
learn to play music first start with
covers then do this um and so like like
for example i'm about to teach my power
writing course again so i took like five
months off
and i'm gonna do it again at the end of
uh end of this month
um and in it i have one section which is
just
the habits you need to become a better
writer and the first one is copywork and
then i make them
do copy work right there and i remember
asking i was like i'm going to use 10
minutes of our course time for you to
write this because i know if i just tell
you to go do this you're not going to
[__] do it you're gonna feel like
it's weird you're gonna say like okay i
get the idea but like i'm not actually
gonna go do that before i need to write
i'm gonna give you one rep at doing this
right now i say go right come back they
come back and i was like what did it
feel like and they're like
they're like it's weird it's like i feel
like my hands aren't my hands they're
their hands it's like my my tongue isn't
my tongue it's their tongue right like
my voice
like i can almost pick up their voice by
the time i'm written the third paragraph
it's like if i then switched and was
writing my own stuff it'd be in that
voice and it's like yeah that's exactly
the point it's like it's a hack to
getting
your stuff to not be flat and boring or
cumbersome and like not be stuck with
writer's block where you just have an
empty page that's intimidating you
so for trends um they were doing this
thing like a contest to see who could
launch a product
and
i was like oh i'll play i'll do this and
so i didn't use my twitter as a way to
promote anything because that would have
been a little unfair but i did use my
facebook and basically i was like i'm
going to create a copywork course i
think i called it copy that or something
nice and um it's just gumroad it was for
50 and i just gathered like my 12
favorite bits of copy
and i
made a pdf and i explained why each part
is interesting and the person who
receives one they receive one every 10
days and they have to write it by hand
and they get commentary as to why it's
cool
and uh i think it's going to be good i
i'm releasing it in like three days and
i've been like spending all my time
doing it that's amazing that's a great
idea what's uh what's the url for that
uh you you liked it so i i don't want to
show the url yet no because that's an
unfair advantage or whatever yeah it's
an unfair advantage but if you go to my
facebook uh you'll see but basically i
tell the story about how here i'll send
it to you about how ben franklin used to
use copywork and it was one of the best
ways to learn how to write but for some
reason we don't do it anymore and i just
did what you did where i talked about
how you get to feel the texture of other
people
it's called uh i just i just call it how
to write irresistible copy
yeah i sent it to you
and there's a lot of um
it's like you know so when i made the
power writing course i was like okay i'm
literally going to only say you have 10
days my goal was i'm going to make you a
like two times better at writing in 10
days that was the mission from the start
and i was like i don't think it's that
hard because most people they themselves
feel like they suck at writing and they
kind of do second writing and but like
most things when you haven't tried to
get great at something or you don't know
how you how to get great you're actually
not that far away a couple tweaks will
get you double like twice as good or
three times as good and then you know to
become the best in the world yeah that's
a whole lifetime of practice but you can
double your skill in pretty much
anything if the right guide gives you
like the right couple things to do
and copywriting uh copywork is one of
those that i was like this is one of the
central ones and people aren't going to
believe me but it works and so
um i yeah i devote one of my little
sections to it in the course by the way
about the course name otherwise they're
gonna get mad at me for talking about
the course and not telling people go go
go do it so i'm teaching it in february
i teach it myself with my bare hands i
it's live on video it's recorded if you
miss it uh and go to
powerwritingcourse.com and so i think we
have like uh
200 spots we opened it up yet like two
days ago 100 people took it already and
wow let's see if it fills up yeah how
many people came to the first time also
200 people
i did 160 the first 150 the first time
and that was capped then the second time
i did no cap and uh it was 350 students
did it oh my god this time i think i'm
going to shut it off after 200
um
but i'm going to teach it yeah basically
i'm going to teach it uh
because i like the slightly smaller
group sizes so i can just give a little
more feedback
because it takes a lot of work because
after the thing you write your thing and
then i go in slack and i'll give you
like direct feedback on it and so that
takes more time than actually teaching
the course or coming up with the content
is like going giving people real
feedback so i don't do it for everybody
but after every session i'll give like
15 20 students direct feedback and then
so over the course of the 10 days you're
gonna get it from me at one point dude
that's sick
uh yeah i know
sarah took the class or did sarah take
it or who some one of my someone i'm
close with took it and they said they
loved it and goggin the founder of maven
said that it was one of the most loved
courses
yeah they actually have hooked me up so
maven is uh really helping me out
because they knew i was lazy i was like
i'm probably never going to teach it
again they're like why it was like one
of the highest rated courses and i was
like well it's just like it's work to
like like what's the work i'm like well
i gotta like send an email out to be
like join it i was like i feel stupid
asking so i'm just like
you know i just don't want to do it um
and like you already made all the
content it's highly rated all you got to
do is like send out two emails so they
just sent it out on my behalf and i was
like thank you all right i'll teach it
then
because i love actual teaching
and look at the home page so if you go
to maven.com you see sean
and then right next to him you see sarah
my wife how funny is that yeah does she
like teaching it she did hers right
yeah she dug it yeah she's doing it
again yeah she will
yeah i think that's the trick is to do
it regularly because you just get better
at teaching it um all right let's do
some other stuff wait but before we do
other stuff uh what's his name ryan is
coming onto the pod so everyone ryan
will be on in like 30 minutes
ryan
he's the founder of bolt and so
basically ryan's pretty impressive dudes
i invested in bolt he has built two
projects that are worth over a billion
dollars and he's under like the age of
28. and recently a bunch of people heard
most people hadn't heard of bolt and
then he went on twitter and started like
basically
he took he took shots at y combinator
and stripe like two of the most beloved
startup organizations and he basically
was like they're the mob they're the
mafia and he's like and why is he's not
worth doing and here's why and so
controversy you're picking a fight
really works
and so uh i want to talk to him about
about that and see where this is
i think he's gonna bring a couple ideas
so so let's
let's talk you want to talk about dan
price well what's your crazy damn prize
story well okay most people probably
don't know this so so you i think you
know
uh because you wrote about it in 2015
which is way ahead of the curve so
listen to that you explain this and then
let me explain my piece let me explain
how this how this happened so i'm
reading so we have this document and
sean was like writing in the document
right before we started and he wrote
crazy damn price story i don't know why
that's that's our little secret we we we
write the topic so you get the other
person curious but you don't you don't
fill in the details so they don't know
what you're gonna say so the reaction's
authentic yes so i don't know what
you're gonna say but in 2015 i wrote
this article and the headline said
so dan price is the guy who kind of
looks like jesus he's based out of
portland i think he's the guy who
famously said from now on everyone the
minimum wage at our company is 70 000 a
year i'm reducing my salary the headline
to the article i wrote in 2015 which at
the time and still has not gotten picked
up a lot it says dan price the gravity
payment ceo paying everyone seventy
thousand dollars is full of [__] turns
out ninety percent of the damn price
story is completely made up but he's
making a fool of all of us
and i and basically i like wrote about
how there's like three things that are
very weird that happened with the story
and a lot of this by the way is opinion
some of it's facts but there's a lot of
uh allegations so
so take that for what it's worth but uh
a few things one prior
to
him raising everyone else's salary to
seventy thousand dollars he was paying
himself 1.1 million dollars and that's
for a company that was only doing 16
million dollars in revenue
well why is that weird well because uh
he was being sued by his brother and his
brother was suing him the brother was
suing dan who's a co-founder the two
brothers were founders was suing dan for
pa dan was paying himself too much money
and it's kind of like
the brother had a profit share the
brother was uh was not active full-time
so he didn't take a salary or had a
small salary he was there for the
profits the funny thing was there's no
profits because the brother is taking a
humongous salary and reducing profits to
like zero so that's why yeah well the
the brother quit so dan goes oh well and
i don't want to share the profit so just
boost my salary and then immediately
the brother sues dan and so he's like oh
well maybe we should reduce my salary
and everyone sally i'm gonna make this
and second and worse he was accused of
listening to this sentence
dan price is accused of repeatedly
waterboarding and beating his wife and
on october 28th this was i think 2015
his ex-wife gave a ted talk where she
talked about how dan was punching her in
the stomach and slapping her in the face
and she had to go lock herself in the
car because she was afraid that he was
gonna like kill her so like crazy stuff
so anyway
i this is allegations but like if it
looks like a duck and quack like a duck
it's a duck there's allegedly a duck
yes
there's just a few things and then
here's another funny thing price said of
himself i'm just so sick of the
attention it just feels a lot like it
she feels like such a big investment of
yourself there's this episode of the
office where michael scott was like
these people wanted to talk to him about
this uh thing going on dunder mifflin
and he goes man i was amazed you know i
was like i didn't want to make a big
deal out of it but like the media was
contacting me so i decided to call a
radio station and
i called this other radio station i did
an interview and you know like it's just
crazy that they're all coming to me
that's like what dan's like he's like
i'm sick of the attention why is
everyone coming
he runs ads promoting the story of the
ceo
who reduced his salary and everybody
else in the company makes seventy
thousand dollars minimum wage and he's
like barefoot and even further you know
the guy doesn't wear shoes he loves the
earth and he loves the world and he says
all ceos are too greedy um you know be
like me and then his employees i don't
know if you heard this part this is
after your this is after
2015 so you probably didn't have this in
your thing
there's this video that goes viral of
his employees gifting him a tesla
because they're like dan you've
sacrificed so much oh my god you haven't
you have so much
we're gonna give you this tesla so they
all pitched in and bought him a tesla
and he's like crying he's overwhelmed uh
blah blah blah so
they got fooled because basically
so yeah he pays himself a high high
salary brother gets mad brother whatever
he ends up buying his brother out at a
discount
cuts his salary still takes the money as
a profit like he still gets the profits
from the company as the
as the owner of the company but it's not
a w-2 salary it's not a salary so it's
actually even more tax advantageous it's
just like you know zuck takes a one
dollar salary because he gets paid in
stock
um
you know it's crazy
and then he and then he makes bank he
does 50 000 speaking gigs doesn't share
that with anybody he has a 500 000 book
deal because of his like story about you
know ceo greed
and uh you know
freaking waterboarded his wife i was
like this is crazy like what what is
going on
um this is a crazy story to me and it
just reminds me of like anytime somebody
really goes out of their way to tell you
how virtuous they are
you can pretty much take it to the bank
that they are they are overcompensating
from for something that they are not as
virtuous as uh as the effort that
they're taking to tell you how virtuous
they are if you're writing
it's like fox news saying fair and
balanced it's like dude like don't piss
on my back and tell me it's raining like
don't lie to me like just be you that's
[Laughter]
just like be honest like like so
like this whole thing that his whole
stick the wife thing is like if that's
true that's obvious that's its own
category and that's unforgivable but the
whole uh pay thing it's like dude like
it's kind of like
it's kind of like lance armstrong a lot
of people aren't mad that lance
armstrong took the drugs
they're mad that he was so cocky about
it that he did a commercial saying what
am i on i'm on my bike eight hours a day
busting my ass what are you on and then
he sued a guy who was accusing him of
taking drugs it's like dude that was the
part that was a little like when you
went
overboard like the statement is worse
than the crime for yes the cover-up is
worse than the crime
uh yeah that's crazy um okay so i want
to do a couple other random things uh i
want to talk about this this business i
heard about that i think is
kind of amazing i don't know if you
looked into it but it's called canna do
you know what i'm talking about
uh
maybe tell me more all right so this guy
uh david friedberg who's gotten really
pop he went from like you know didn't
have a twitter account to now very
popular because he's on he's one of the
four people on the all in podcast which
is pretty popular podcast um
you know if they're you know
if we're not the best podcast in the
world you know they're their second best
type of thing you know they're a great
podcast so
basically it's chamath it's jason
kalkanis it's david sacks and then it's
this guy friedberg and pretty much
everybody had heard everything in the
tech world or heard of the other three
nobody knew about freedberg and
friedberg has been like the um
the like you know the revelation he's
actually you know my favorite one of the
pod and many people's favorite one of
the pod why is that well he's kind of
like a science background and he's an
engineer like scientist who goes into
business and so the first business he
built was called climate corporation
and um it's ended up it was basically
telling farmers about um
whether it was like weather data and
kind of like giving farmers uh
information about what they should be
doing with their crops and things like
that so it was like a data company for
farmers i i don't know a ton about it
but i think that and and i think they
raised a relatively small sum for the
amount of which they sold for right so
actually i should go back he was early
google pre-ipo he was like uh one of
larry page's favorite people the founder
ceo of google at the time and he was
working on special projects for them
then he left he starts climate
corporation ends up selling it to
monsanto the big evil you know whatever
company in the agriculture space
um
then he starts yeah for like a billion
dollars then he starts um
this company that's uh what's it called
last night
well metro mile so it's an insurance
company and it was a pretty innovative
idea it's like
get in your car and instead of like if
you don't drive your car much why should
you pay the same amount for insurance as
somebody who drives a ton right so it's
like pay per mile
insurance and even better it was like
they installed a little thing in your
car or whatever it could basically see
do you speed a lot or not if you don't
speed a lot you should pay less for
insurance so it's like a dynamic form of
insurance that was a cool idea ended up
going public in a spack and then
famously the spat kind of has crashed
since then it's it's been obliterated
it got bought by lemonade for you know
like a third of what it went public for
so you know marketing is is 209 it
previous market cap was like 4 billion
yeah so uh so ended up getting acquired
you know whatever the public story
wasn't great but you know built a
company that ended up
going you know generating hundreds of
millions of dollars uh so so anyways
another good win so now he's got a new
company so he actually he has a he has
like an incubator for himself called the
production board and basically it's like
not vc it's like google backed it for
like a billion dollars or something
crazy and then blackrock and a couple
others backed it for so it's raised a
ton of money and all it does is it
builds its own companies in-house one of
the companies that they just announced i
think is really cool so anyways that's a
bunch of backstory and by the way i
think i got like a third of that wrong
but whatever you get the general idea of
who the guy is
so his new company is pretty dope
and it's this trend i've been trying to
follow which is 3d printing but it's
basically printing beverages at home so
what does that mean they're going to
give people a machine so you buy this
machine and think of it like a printer
and it sits in your kitchen
and when you want to have a drink
whether that's you want um you know like
a lacroix you want sparkling water with
lemon flavor you want a hot tea you want
a white claw with alcohol in it you want
a white wine whatever drink you want you
push a button
and it'll dispense that beverage for you
and it does this because they basically
realize and he tells the story it's
pretty dope he tells a story that like
um
he was at a dinner and the scientist is
there and the scientist is kind of
educating him on this he's like you know
almost every drink is all water right so
juice is like 94 water uh coca-cola is
like 95 water wine is like 95 water
everything's like 90 plus percent water
and and then you know it's like x
percent sugar and alcohols and then like
one percent is the flavoring that gives
it the unique taste that makes it taste
like iced tea to you
um and it's only one percent of what's
actually in the beverage
and it's like so isn't it crazy that we
like have factories that produce you
know we we go we get we get all these
like chemicals and water and whatever we
put in the factory then we put it into
bottles then we put the bottles on a
truck we truck it to a store it sits on
their shelf then you drive to that store
you take it off that shelf you drive it
home you put it on your shelf at home
and it's in a bottled plastic thing that
then goes into the you know recycling or
the trash and
wow that's a lot for like something
that's basically water and we all have
water in our own homes piped you know
already through the water system so like
why why instead of doing this central
manufacturing and like kind of
brutalizing the environment and having
this high cost
why can't i just
add the flavoring at the end point at
your home
using the water that you already have
and create these beverages on the fly
and so after years of like r d and
testing they've basically got it to the
fact where here's what they do the
machine basically takes your water and
they can either make the water really
cold really hot
or carbonated and then it has three
cartridges there's a sugar cartridge
there's an alcohol cartridge and then
there's the flavor cartridge
and all you do is you just select what
drink you want and it'll say okay we're
going to put out like one microliter of
you know
of this assorbic acid because that's
what gets you the soda taste and then
we're going to add some sugar and then
we've got no alcohol because it's a soda
or if it's a white wine it's going to be
like here's the alcohol a little bit of
sugar and then here's the flavoring
that's going to give it that you know
the the
the palette of of a white wine and so
and the idea is that with those three
cartridges you can make basically an
infinite combination of drinks because
one the flavor cartridge itself has like
different flavors inside of it that can
be mixed and matched
and so i think this is kind of amazing
it's going to be like let's say you
could pull this off
now all of a sudden we're not buying
bottled drinks everywhere we're just
able to at our end point have any drink
we want for any you know my mom wants
tea my dad wants wine i want soda and my
wife wants flavored water she we can all
get that out of the same device for a
few it's just like a
it's like a better coke freestyle
machine you know coke that's exactly the
analysis i
love it's the at-home mini freestyle
that can do
10 10 times more than what the freestyle
could do i used to go to the movie
theater near my place in san francisco i
would never see a movie but i would walk
into the lobby just to get a coke from
the freestyle machine because you could
make coke zero cherry vanilla or coke
zero orange vanilla and i loved it and
it's the only place you could do that
and so i tried to get one for my office
and the terms were ridiculous it was
something like a hundred dollars a month
for life or like it's like a it's like a
crazy like it's it's they make it
challenging to get a freestyle machine
and they are so cool and they are so
good and so this is just like a home
freestyle machine but for every drink
ever right yeah cause you know like as
kids we used to go to like the normal
soda fountain that has like 10 spouts
and it's like you do the rainbow you
just put all of them in the cup and it's
like oh that's how i want my drink right
and freestyle took it one step further
because you could be like i want orange
i want like it's the long tail of
flavors so you could be like i like
black cherry
mountain dew and i might be only 0.1
percent so like mountain dew can't
afford to bottle that because they're
like dude it's such a small market but
with this it's like the long tail of
flavors gets done and so the analogy is
like it's like tv so back when we had
three channels they could only program
the most general stuff that the average
consumer is going to want so if you're a
fishing enthusiast and we only have
three channels on tv it's not going to
work for you but then you get cable and
now you get you know hundreds of
channels let's say so now there's a
dedicated phishing channel
but then let's say then youtube comes
along and youtube's like no we can
literally anybody can create from their
own home and now we'll have every
variation so you want only bass fishing
in spanish because you're a spanish
speaker well now there's a channel for
you
and um and so that's the same idea the
way that we did it with content where
once the means of production went to the
home now you got every single supply
demand like niche got filled uh that's
going to happen now with beverages where
every flavor is going to be done and
even better you get the economic savings
you get the environmental savings you
get the flavor personalization right
like start one of the reasons starbucks
is so successful is because my wife can
go in there and order a venti skinny you
know latte half decaf with oat milk
light ice and blah blah and with you
know one pack of stevia and it's like
her drink is her drink and starbucks is
willing to do that whereas you go to you
know normal coffee shop you can't get
can't get that done
so that's going to be at the home and
even further now
it also creates a business model
for so like me and you we could
basically say
say sam loves root beer we could create
my first million root beer
all we do we don't have to find a
manufacturer and a bottler and a
whatever all we do is we just create a
recipe it's a piece of software it's
like it's like a piece of content you
know it's a it's just like three
variables
and we could just send it to your device
and you could print it out for you know
55 cents
and we would get our share of the
royalty from everybody who does that and
so all of a sudden you're gonna see just
like the rock made his own tequila
instead of george clooney
it'll that will go down to you don't
need 100 million followers to do that
you could now have 10 000 followers on
instagram and create your own beverage
and people could print it at home and
you could get your share of that how
cool first of all
diet root beer is one of the best sodas
of all time
because it has no caffeine so you can
drink it any hour of the day it's not
sprite it sprites whack and it's diet no
calories and it's like creamy it's the
best the second point was it's not
sprite well because like you could do i
used to drink diet like seven up
sometimes but like that's like some
ratchet stuff but it's got it it's just
that's kind of weak that's like a a
refreshing i want like a hearty creamy
thing so i used to drink a diet root
beer a day but for some reason in san
francisco i could only find it in the
asian neighborhood so my office the
craigslist office was in an asian
neighborhood and so i've always wondered
like do asian people love it
they were um
the vitamins grocery store always had
the best selection of diet root beers
they have like four different types
uh anyway i love that gets a 23andme
test
just enough
in me
the second thing is we used to have this
lit list of um
companies that you should work at in
order to like get rich that are growing
i would put this on that list and what
was the name of his uh people what was
that tpb the production board
and it's basically it's like the i think
the theory is like
we have to produce real things for the
world to move to work and what if we
could rethink the way that production
happens in these different systems so
okay how does quinoa get made how does
how do beverages get made how does uh
you know like
uh this one fertilizer get made and if
we can find a way to use new
technologies to like improve the means
of production those are all big
industries i think that and they've got
overall thesis lab generated protein or
like lab generated meat he's a vegan for
example so he's like you know he agreed
with me which he said something that's
pretty controversial he's like i think
that the way
people will look back on what we do with
animals and see it as worse than slavery
and then people got really mad at him
for saying that and he's like no like
just i meant it okay i'm not saying it's
it is worse than human slavery i'm
saying that the scale of mass murder
that happens on an everyday basis
there's no comparable to it
i'm on board with that the other day i
ordered uh i ate 15 hot wings
and i was like i just ate seven and a
half chickens
[Music]
you